good morning this is my 21st public
conference talk on my first keynote so I
thought I'm gonna use this opportunity
to get a little personal and through
that lens inspire you to make the world
a better place by contributing to python
the talk will go roughly as follows
I'm Mukesh I'm bad at math I used to
stock Michael Ford when I was younger
and it's all pure luck anyway you can
contribute to Python just like I did but
Python is not the same as it was when I
first started but maybe that's a good
thing where are all the new developers
hiding these days and shouldn't we be
writing JavaScript anyway so this is how
this will go down let's start at the
beginning
I'm Mukesh 10 years ago I can have my
comic bit yet and 15 years ago I didn't
even know Python existed today I'm a
Python Software Foundation fellow I'm
the reason of the two versions of Python
other in current development which is
Python three point eight and three point
nine and you know what I offered an
co-authored 11 peps to date and last
year I started like a pet project to
scratch my own itch which is called
Black Sun opening I did Python code for
a matter anybody here heard of it so
thank you well job wise my biggest two
employers were Allegro in Poland and
Facebook in Vancouver British Columbia
Menlo Park California and London here in
London well I used Python at both
companies specifically in my five years
at Facebook I helped migrate a few
million lines of code to Python three
six at a time you might have heard of a
particle e fun part of it in Lisa gross
and Hui dings Instagram keynote at PyCon
u.s. 2017 but 15 years back I didn't
know Python was a thing I was a
terrified computer science student at
boson University of Technology in Poland
struggling with linear algebra in
particular
in fact I was doing so badly that I was
faced with a final exam retake if I fail
this one I would be kicked out of the
university so obviously I studied hard
for this I didn't want that to happen
but the subject matter was away over my
head I felt much more comfortable with
high school math that fit my brain well
so I went through an entire book of
exercises to ensure that I'm gonna pass
this time that book listed answers to
problems at the back which was very
helpful but a set of extra difficult
ones marked with an asterisk were left
out so I knew like these would be the
ones on the exam right and lo and behold
the day before the exam my friend told
me hey I'm using a Ruby script you know
to check that the answers are correct
well it doesn't show you how to achieve
those answers but at least you see
whether the numbers are the same so I
got really excited he showed it with me
I felt really relieved I got back home I
downloaded our Ruby installer I click
Next Next and it crashed
I found another version and next next
and it crashed and so with a few more
versions so at this point I had to claim
defeat and I got really desperate so I
Lily typed in Google Ruby alternative
this is how I found Python and that
installer worked well soon after I was
following a python tutorial trying to
convert my friends script from a
language I didn't know to another
language I didn't know as any reasonable
student does when faced with an
important exam the very next day
astonishingly it kind of worked I kind
of managed to kinda convert enough of
the script to kinda confirm my answers
were right so I got relieved and the
next day I passed the exam
had the Ruby installer work that crucial
day I would not be here today as most
other major life events of mine that was
pure luck and this is something I
strongly believe in but all successful
people owe a lot to chance more than
most of them would care to admit
but as Kent Beck who am I used to work
with says if you wanna win you need to
play quit yelling from the stands and
get on the field make a prediction see
what actually happens so a few years
later still at university I worked on a
research project for the Polish
equivalent of the Scotland Yard
programming Italian microcontrollers
with GSM and GPS functionality amazingly
they were programmed with a bastardized
version of Python 1.6 so I badly wanted
to spread the knowledge that it's
incredible to program hardware with
Python to understand this that was 2007
hours
five years before the release of
Raspberry Pi so I responded to a call
for proposals to my first conference the
talk didn't go well by the end of my
slot I was roughly halfway through my
slides and I attempted live coding which
went particularly bad that section was
as awkward as it gets people started
sending live text messages to the phone
number of the microcontroller they saw
on the screen so Michael Ford was in the
audience he was also there talking about
ironpython at the time is he in the
audience today he's at the event so I
say hi to him if you see him later I
asked him for feedback he took me aside
and he gave me some of the harshest
feedback I've ever received
I was accurate and helpful so thank you
Michael two years later I attended euro
Python in Birmingham that was my first
international conference and Michael
Ford pictured here was the only face I
recognized so naturally I shamelessly
followed him around
in fact you have to believe me that this
guy right here that's me more
importantly I had no idea what his
prints meant I thought they were a
mandatory part of the event so I booked
my travel and booked my hotel to just
attend all days of Sprint's I didn't
know what they were and Michael at the
sprints was the only person I knew so he
helped me with my first attempts to
contribute to python that particular
sprint was not very productive in the
end for me I'm sorry Michael
I wasted too much time on SVN too much
time setting up my environment so that
the right libraries were there so Python
even builds what that experience taught
me a very important lesson Sprint's are
amazing you get to work with actual
maintained errs on actual problems with
their software you get to see actual
development done in practice live and
you have experts on hand to nag about
your new problems this is something that
you could not buy even if you wanted so
even though all of this was pure chance
for me that I even stayed for the
sprints in the first place
and it was kind of in large part naivete
on my part it was enough to inspire me
to come back the next year and that time
I came prepared and a few weeks later I
got my commitment so you have to show up
but if you are already on your feet
helping new commerce might have
tremendous impact on their future lives
I know it had on mine so you know what I
wouldn't be here today without Raymond
Hellinger without cuido van Rossum Fred
Drake and York Brandel
all of whom spent tens of hours with me
both in person and online
sometimes at very inconvenient times of
day due to time zone differences and I
will forever be in their debt today on
the reefs manager if I could do it you
can too but there's a snag
many core developers rightfully
mentioned that following my footsteps as
I described them will not be as easy as
it was for me
Python got much bigger now it has to be
much more stable compared to ten years
ago and got much much more complex as
well in other words most low-hanging
fruit already picked what's left is
maintenance of an increasingly
fossilized
interpreter and Stunna library what kind
of maintenance is both tedious and
tricky especially for a dynamic
interpreter language like Python with
compiled languages we can compile a
program with an old compiler and then it
runs on new boxes just fine with Python
you write your program and maybe it
won't run on next Red Hat you don't know
python is the biggest community run
programming language on the planet other
programming languages with similar or
larger market penetration Iran by
corporations either single corporations
or Committees of multiple ones being a
community project is both a blessing and
a curse for Python it's a blessing
because it's truly free it's truly free
from shareholder pressure and market
swings so it's gonna be there for you in
10 years in 20 years I should know I'll
be releasing versions of Python 3.9 for
you all the way to 2025 well but being a
community Ram project is also a curse
almost the entire core developer team is
volunteering their time and effort for
free while the Python Software
Foundation is graciously funding
infrastructure and events like bike on
us and the annual week-long Python core
spread it does not currently employ any
core developers since there is both
Python and software right in the name of
the foundation I want this to change if
you don't pay people you have no
influence over what they work on core
developers often choose problems to
tackle based on what inspires them
personally so we never had an explicit
roadmap there's never been a road map
where Python should go what problems
core developers should focus on to be
fair I have to mention that you know
as long as we had Guido as the
benevolent dictator he did most of the
vision work himself he ran many projects
personally and behind the scenes he
sparked inspiration in core developers
to do other project that he found are
important but more importantly he
stopped proposals quickly for things
that he was dead set against so that
Python could stay consistent with what
he saw as being high chthonic but this
is very hard to maintain as a single
person it's a very hard task and you
need to work with people and you know
agree and disagree so today python is no
longer governed by a ruby FL my personal
hope is that the steering council will
be providing visionary guidance from now
on and will present us with an explicit
roadmap for where we should go
I'm not on the steering council in fact
the release manager position is a bit of
a misnomer what I am actually managing
is the timely release of source tarballs
and with help of net Billy and Steve
tower binaries for Windows and Mac OS so
I have no say in what goes in and what
people choose to work on the only thing
I can do is if they land their changes
too late or if there are too disruptive
because they're incomplete they have
buggies or they're backwards
incompatible I can decide to revert
those but as anybody who wants to keep
working on a team like you will not use
that hammer very liberally so I'm not on
the steering council but since you're
already here listening to me let me
share what I would like to see happen to
Python anyway before I get there let me
reveal that I wasn't completely honest
with you all along I kept using the word
Python but what I really meant in most
cases was see Python the reference
implementation of the language the
reference interpreter written in C that
most of us are using for their
day-to-day Python needs the snag I
described earlier applies to C Python
alone that's the
interpreter that is run by a team of
volunteers with an insanely important
focus on backwards-compatibility
but the focus that is in many ways
crippling that cpython is gonna be
maintained for decades but drastic
changes are very hard and thus unlikely
because of that I would argue that if
Python stays synonymous with C Python
for too long we'll be in big trouble
why because C Python is not available
where developer trends are shifting for
web the lingua franca is JavaScript now
for the two biggest operating systems on
mobile we have Swift the modern take on
Objective C and we have Copeland the
modern take on Java for VR and AR and
many you know 3d games we have C sharp
provided by unity a tremendously popular
option Python is also slowly losing
ground in the field of systems
orchestration that was very close to my
heart we're going traction OpenStack
used to be all Python perhaps if not the
rise of machine learning and artificial
intelligence which were unforeseen by
the core developers Python would have
not survived the transition between
Python 2 and 5 and 3 so we got really
lucky there but if you think that what I
just said is like sad negative
depressing or fatalistic well think
again in the 2018 developer survey ran
by Stack Overflow
we learned that python is the third most
loved programming language out there
better yet it is the most wanted'
language by far people want to use it so
why aren't they using it well let's look
at another result from the same survey
looks like we're already the seventh
most popular language in use but looking
above it becomes plausible to think that
providing a clear supported and official
option for client-side web is what
Python needs in order to satisfy the
Legion of people that want to use it we
are already the fastest growing major
programming language after all that's an
article from 2017 I recommend reading it
if you haven't seen it yet among other
things it says we
27 percent year-over-year growth rate
Python stands alone as attack that is
both large and growing rapidly so C
Python is doing just fine
but for Python the programming language
to need to reach new heights we need a
new kind of Python and this is where you
come in truly tremendous impact awaits 9
series here for a new runtime or a new
compiler unencumbered by the constraints
of C Python targeting a new trending
platform this can become career-defining
work you will make the world a better
place that way at face value what I
propose is crazy
there were many unsuccessful attempts to
create a new Python the runtime after
all don't I know it
remember this picture right here
that's the Python VM panel at your
Python 10 years ago from the left you
can see call friedrich bolts from
pipeline you can see mark Shannon
representing hot pie which is now a
defunct project he is a C Python core
developer you can see Michael Ford
representing ironpython now a defunct
project he's a C Python core developer
you can see Frankie SBT representing
JSON now a defunct project you can see
your brand will representing C Python
York is no longer active we miss you
York and then you have Damian deed
representing cross twine again a defunct
project there's a few people missing
from this picture you could add
maintainer zuv unladen swallow you could
add maintainer zuv piston and a few
others in fact the only two runtimes
left of this picture are C Python and
pipeline and pi pi is an amazing project
it tries to be bug to bug compatible
with C Python and that is still too hard
for many users to consider switching
from C Python to pipeline in fact I
spent a week in Dusseldorf in Germany
this winter at a sprint that pipe I was
running
I met a lot of the core team they are
wonderful people you should meet them
and you should listen to them I got a
comment with myself Oh
seems like pi PI gives out it rather
liberally I solved a few Python 3.6
compatibility issues so I guess I'm not
entirely you know ashamed or getting
that commit bit so so fast but I learned
a thing that in hindsight is obvious but
I never quite like thought clearly about
it before pi pi is known to be the
implementation of Python written in
Python but it's written in Python too
it's one of the most complex
applications in the industry written in
Python - what that means that without a
tremendous investment it is very
unlikely to ever migrate to Python 3 it
is just too complex especially that
those people are very clever there's
plenty of meta programming so Python
code generating more Python code which
then is translated to see and then
compiled to native code so pi PI will
have to keep Python to support as long
as they want to be able to bootstrap
themselves which they want because it's
a most performant runtime that we have
for Python trying to replicate the
Python bug to bug with all its behavior
and all the stunt library is super hard
and I'm skeptical of new developments
force in Python replacements without a
multi-million dollar investment over
many years I don't think that's feasible
but areas of modern focus where Python
currently has no penetration I already
mentioned mobile client-side web er AR
all those don't require full
compatibility with C Python do you
really need your C extensions on your
mobile web browser probably not and that
is good news since Python has amazed
many features that are hard to optimize
and make static analysis and fast I des
fail so there's no time now to enumerate
the entire laundry list of Python
features that I think is plausible that
we could feasibly simplify given a new
platform but let me show you a few
examples the import system is a very
complex beast
describes how modules are imported it
describes how packages namespace
packages work describes search describes
a runtime writable module cash finders
and loaders including how we find
modules and packages on the file system
and sis not path and stuff but also how
you can write custom ones that run your
modules from a database memory or you
name it
import hooks meta paths like I could go
on but do we really need that on the web
or on VR on mobile what people want on
mobile is to just go to their App Store
click install and have like their small
binary quickly load over their 3G
network somewhere in rural Pennsylvania
right so do we really need that on a web
no like people want again to have a
small application so that their website
runs fast and has a fast time to
interact in fact one of gos claims to
fame is that they shipped static
binaries so you only have one file you
can choose to still use containers but
you don't have to you don't have virtual
ends you don't have tip installs you
don't have environments that you have to
orchestrate you know being created and
then teardown exec is again like a
feature of Python that provides
tremendous value but for a price many
people now consider it as an
anti-pattern
they don't want to see it in their code
if any user controlled input ends up in
exec that's a security vulnerability but
even if not it obscures what is
happening to your code from humans and
static analysis and is very tricky to
make that performant metaclasses are a
way of extending the idea that if we
already have done revenue and under init
to control how we instantiate object how
about we had a way to control how we
instantiate classes python is using meta
classes internally a lot and third-party
libraries and frameworks like Django are
utilizing it as well but again it makes
it hard to see at first what python is
actually gonna do
when you are interacting with your class
which also defeats much of static
analysis and is a form of interaction
making things slower parts of the data
model in Python are very dynamic which
might not be necessary descriptors are
away for an object to control how it
behaves when it is an attribute on
another class they were added in python
2.2 as part of new style classes and in
fact part of their motivation was to
simplify how c python is implemented and
now we have properties class methods and
super actually using the descriptive
protocol themselves but it's also a
generic way for Python users to write
like powerful class and object behavior
but again it's indirection an
indirection equals bad because it's slow
and it also makes it harder for us to
see the shape of our objects what is the
shape while many programming languages
rely on the fact that they know what a
given object provides as methods and as
attributes and using that knowledge they
can optimize our how an object is
preserved in memory making them smaller
and making attribute accesses and method
calls faster in Python everything is
mutable so we can add and remove
attributes at any given point in time we
can add any remove methods as well but
did you know since Python 3.7 module
support dunder get adder we support it
so that you can customize module
attribute access and we already
supported customizing the underclass
since Python 3.5 what that means is you
can take a module object and set its
dunder class attribute to something else
why what did I just say like you can lie
about what class a given object is yes
and it enables pretty advanced
functionality in fact mercurial uses it
for plugins you know a few others as
well so you know what I feels like it's
useful for some advanced cases but it
makes it very hard to see what is
happening and it makes alternative
runtimes very hard to write
I could go on the point is starting out
with a familiar subset of Python for the
user that looks like Python would
simplify development of a new runtime or
compiler a lot and potentially would
even fit the target platform better
don't believe me look at micro Python a
single programmer daemon George started
development on it from scratch six years
ago in Australia funding his work with a
Kickstarter campaign and now it's a
surprisingly compatible runtime for
microcontrollers that have very little
memory and by very little I mean 16
kilobytes of RAM and 256 kilobytes for
code memory and minimal computing power
it finds tremendous uses in as a
teaching past form in the BBC micro bit
that you for sure heard about an
Adafruit silk circuit playground and a
few others but also production use in
home automation and MIDI controllers and
game consoles like pew-pew
I'm hearing it will be distributed to
Europe Python attendees this year I
highly recommend getting one it's great
fun and uh the creator of it is a friend
of mine I know that he cares about it
really much so for correctness I should
mention that some of the use cases I
talked about are powered by a friendly
Fork of micro Python called circuit
Python this is focused on teaching more
it has like a list of innovations one of
them being if you connect your piece of
hardware to your computer it just
appears as a thumb drive and if you edit
your files and save them it restores
your hardware so we can see what you
just did right away which provides like
an amazingly short feedback loop for
what you're doing but more interestingly
I kept talking about ways in which C
Python could be you know simplified to
make other platforms easier to develop
for and you're a Python are you're a
Python micro Python has a list of things
that it decides not to implement or
implement differently some of them are
just restrictions of what you can do is
with when faced with a very tight
programming environment but some of them
are just decide
because of either developer efficiency
or because they just fit the user better
amazingly micro Python is still an
interpreter when you connect your device
over USB you can hit control-c and when
ever then get a fabulous repple that's
impressive you can for example run Derr
on the board module to get available
pins on your circuit board and how cool
is that but well you need ctrl C on your
client-side web application running on
your phone I guess not instead we need a
compiler for web we don't need an
interpreter running on top of the web
platform we need something that compiles
your Python code to the web platform
directly that means you cannot achieve
full C Python compatibility from the
get-go as C Python enables plenty of
dynamic runtime behavior some example I
listed before but I think we could
probably do without but there are things
we cannot do it out to be viable for
professional production use Python on
the web
must not be orders of magnitude slower
than the default option which is already
better supported has better
documentation training and is the focus
on of the developers of the browsers
same for mobile and especially on an
increasingly popular intersection that I
kept mentioning which is the mobile web
browser very often when people think of
mobile they think of their beefy laptop
running Chrome or Firefox but what
should you you should really be thinking
about is your phone in your pocket you
don't want your Python program to drain
the battery on this one or make the
device unresponsive
thus a compiler that's a hard path but
in my opinion that's inevitable luckily
there's some prior art that we can
either improve adapt reuse or maybe just
take inspiration from there's Nootka
their site understand or shed skin
there's Python this number they have
different focus but they all implement
roughly the idea I'm talking about but
the one I wanted to focus for a moment
is my I see the probably the new
best player in town what my PI C does is
it takes modern Python 3 code which is
type annotated and generates fast Python
C extensions so C extensions for C
Python but it is already using
production for my PI the type checker
making it four times as fast that's
plenty impressive what is even more
interesting is that my PI C to achieve
its performance metric and to make this
entire compilation thing of viable
already describes that it was gonna work
for a subset of Python our Python
language variant that we call strict
some of the things that it says is type
annotations have to be enforced at
runtime have to be correct but it also
says classes are compiled without dunder
dict
which is a hash access to find your
attributes which again indirection bad
so obviously they do that when
monkey-patching doesn't work you think
oh isn't that a good thing
monkey-patching obscures what is
happening is this an anti-pattern we
should not be using it but really you
are using it if you ever write unit
tests with the mock module marks patch
is monkey-patching
so how would that work well the compiler
would have to be a bit smaller and
recognize use cases like this to allow
them in very constrained environments
but for everything else
we don't need monkey patching it in fact
is better to not have it instance
attributes one for back to class
attributes if they're undefined and meta
classes that I already mentioned are not
supported so it's not just a theoretical
thing that I mentioned C Python is an
interpreter so it runs an eval loop over
op codes that you've got for example
from a py C file and it then dispatches
what to do just to time very often
delegating behavior to down their
methods or some hash lookups the
compiler should not just inline that
eval eval loop into native instructions
that are executed one by one because
that is just a worse version of a
full-fledged interpreter it's just
better to like you know retain the
interpreter in that case and have all
the flexibility but what I'm talking
about is a compiler that
moves as much of the special method
handling and hash new cups from runtime
to pre-compiled
as possible if you expected I would now
reveal I have one running I have to
disappoint you between the release
manager position blacks family and
unrelated hobbies come talk to me about
analog synthesizers I have little time
for a big project like this but what
about you what about your organization
what about sponsoring such effort could
the PSF font that maybe we need a
Kickstarter campaign I'd be happy to be
on a team paid to work on a thing like
this but what if you want to work on C
Python well I'm not saying that C Python
is a dead end it will forever be an
important runtime for Python probably
the dominant one it's the reference
implementation new people are still both
welcome and needed in fact Pablo Galindo
Salgado just got his commit bit last
year and he's already more impactful
than many long timers so no C Python is
no dead end however working on C Python
today is different from working on it
ten years ago the runtime is
mission-critical in many industries
which is why I develop and must be
extremely careful that way we reach the
final point to be honest with ourselves
we have to ask if maybe it's okay for
Python to not be available on those
newfangled platforms
well I strongly believe that enabling
Python or new platforms is important
work this is Alan Kay the pioneer of
object-oriented programming and
graphical user interfaces one of the
things that he said in a talk given a
few years back was one of our many
problems with thinking this cognitive
load the number of things we can pay
attention to at once the cliche is seven
plus minus two but many things make it
even less we make progress by making
those few things be more powerful this
is one of the reasons mathematicians
like compact notation
the downside is X
to our layers of abstraction and new
cryptic things to learn that's the
practice part of violently but once you
can do this what you can think about at
once has been vastly magnified Python is
an extremely expressive language when I
first started I was amazed how much you
can accomplish with just a few lines of
code especially compared to Java but
there are languages even more expressive
and enabling even more compact notation
so what makes Python special python is
run above pseudocode it reads like
English is very elegant Edsger Dijkstra
said that elegance is not a dispensable
luxury but a quality that decides
between success and failure well I would
like to agree with them
but in my experience convenience all too
often wins out over cue ality of
experience so our responsibility is to
make our run above pseudocode convenient
to use for new programmers because when
it is convenient to use it is very
popular in teaching let me give you just
two examples here's a room full of
musicians figuring out Python for the
first time they're musicians they are
making their software synthesizers play
using circuit pythons medic abilities so
their programming a microcontroller to
play notes on their software
synthesizers that was at Mach fest this
year in North Carolina it's a music
festival people were amazed that at the
same day they learned how to program
hardware and learned about Python and
they could be productive from day one
just like I did on my first day with
Python let me introduce you to another
guy that Stanley does my son back in
2013 he was five at the time trying his
first steps with a troll module on a
Raspberry Pi that he that I got at PyCon
us that year I will always remember
is pure joy when he by himself made the
turn would go where he wanted now he's
almost 11 we still have fun with Python
mostly with the pew pew console but if
his first programming language one he
uses now on a tiny piece of hardware
that costs 8 pounds would be directly
applicable in his later life to use at
his job that would be incredible we the
current generation of software
developers could make those future lives
easier and so much better by bridging
the gap between the micro bit and
production mobile devices that everybody
is using and we could also build some
job security for ourselves and that
can't be a bad thing but we could really
enable a future generation of software
developers and maybe one day at their
own conferences they would say if I
could you can - thank you very much
[Applause]
well we have some time for questions
all right while compiled two web what
about back-end developers what about
scientists oh that we already covered
those cases pretty well I guess right we
have C Python and that works
tremendously well like if we make type I
better so that people can more easily
migrate to that that will also become
more popular so I guess the platforms
that we already support we just need to
improve those and that we can do
gradually and the core team is doing
that for C Python but many new users of
computing don't run servers themselves
they don't have a laptop they don't have
a stack a stationary PC they only have
an iPad or only have a phone so this is
a place where Python does not exist at
the moment
very interesting - thank you very much
there's this project by Mozilla called
by iodide or something - yes compiles a
subset of scientific Python to
webassembly can you comment a little bit
yeah so there's a few projects already
like Brighton like bio dyed like a Rasta
Python which also comes out to a
compiler webassembly what they do they
approach creating a full-fledged
interpreter that just runs on top of the
web platform which i think is an
interesting idea but it delegates Python
to this future where it always is slower
than JavaScript it always is slower than
what is the default and I think this is
enough to make this inconvenient to
convince both big companies and then
smaller users to write any programs that
way thank you that was extremely
interesting and thought-provoking you
mentioned that the transition from
Python 2 to Python 3 was painful in ways
that were not expected beforehand and
then that Python in all sense was
rescued from from its end by the
unexpected success in data science and
machine learning and this is a pattern
that everything always seems to be
unexpected I mean until we look back on
it and then it seems obvious so if the
future is so difficult for us to guess
where are we going to how are we going
to know where to put our bets on the
future of Python what what things what
platforms use cases are we going to
invest in since we always seem to be
surprised by what actually does happen
well it's hard to predict especially the
future right but what I learned on my
time at Facebook is that like you just
need to take those guesses and run with
them and run with them enough but it's
either be becomes obvious that the
problem was a bit harder than you
anticipated or that the world just went
in a different way as Kent Beck said
like you need to play to win right like
if if we just keep doing what we're
doing now we're gonna mess up
transition right like an those leaps are
what actually provides progress in
computing science I'd like before iPhone
like Apple was a different company you
know I think there's there's plenty of
examples where there were major shifts
in the entire industry if you already
see them happening which I think
webassembly is one of them like we would
just it would be responsible for us to
try this out in earnest Christian
hi so you mentioned the restricted
runtime environment for my PI C also
know that pi PI has a are Python
interpreter which is also a restricted
subset of Python without yes some of
these very very very similar so would it
be maybe a good idea to standardize
something in C Python where you have a
subset of Python feature that we know we
can optimize and have a way to flag code
or in spec run code in this restricted
environment yes ah but the way you get
there is to have an alternative platform
that informs you what that constrained
version of the language should be if you
try to predict the future of what our
people are going to need like you're
likely gonna just end up with a design
that is artificial and not necessarily
useful our Python in particular was
created with an explicit goal to be able
for pi pi to compile that subset to
efficiency that then can be compiled so
that was there efficient goal we can't
use our Python it's Python too high
excellent you know really really great I
just wanted to kind of make a similar
point so you were both Christian and you
were saying that there's a subset of
things that effectively make Python very
pythonic which is this dynamic nature of
changing things so making metaclasses
takes all this introspection
monkey-patching that is very core at
least for me - what python is but those
are there's a there's a contradiction
there towards making it compiler well if
you will
how do you feel that that works how do
you feel that python is should move
towards being more compiler friendly or
I'm not saying Python as the entire
programming language should just abandon
what it is now it's a Python being
dynamic and whatnot but what I'm saying
is a Python like experience with enough
support on a platform where everybody is
is just in comm incomparably better than
no support at all because you just
cannot get the last
10% of support running on that
particular platform so obviously I would
prefer for us to be able to just keep
Python exactly as is and just move it to
all new platforms but as I said like
without multi-million dollar investments
over many years that's not feasible and
even in the end you're gonna end up with
a runtime that is slower than the
default option on that given platform
all right thank you very much
[Applause]
you